gamespot news update time I'm Chris
waters and according to a senior
producer on the xbox 360 version of
titanfall the game runs at a lower frame
rate than on the Xbox one but it is
still quote the true experience Daryl
Allison of Blue Point games the
developer of the xbox 360 version of the
game posted an update on the titanfall
website he said titanfall on the xbox
360 is the true experience the game
looks great sounds great and above all
it plays great there are of course some
differences that are due to the
technical limitations of the hardware
for example the game runs above 30
frames per second but the experts at
respawn worked with us to ensure that
the intense 6v6 while running Titan
dropping action is there by comparison
the xbox one version aims to run at 60
frames per second but drops occasionally
Allison said the choice to delay the
xbox 360 release of titanfall was the
right call and the extra time has paid
off the game was originally set to
launch alongside the xbox one version
but was subsequently delayed to april
eight some lucky gamers have found early
copies floating around various retail
outlets but the game's 360 servers won't
come online until the game officially
launches next Tuesday which means the
games about review for titanfall on the
xbox 360 is probably going to come on
Wednesday come back and we'll see you
then